اعلن رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الفاني اعلن
مساهمه دوله قطر بمبلغ 20 مليون دولار
لدعم مبادره تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه بهدف
مساعده البلدان الافريقيه على الحصول على
الصادرات الغذائيه من هذه المنطقه وشدد
رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري على
ضروره وقف القتال وحمايه المدني
واكدنا استعداد دوله قطر الكامل للمساهمه
في اي جهد دولي واقليمي يرمي الى التوصل
لحرس سلمي وفوري لهذه الازمه ونحن على
يقين بان الطريق الوحيده للنجاح في ذلك هي
ابقار كافه قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه وفي هذا
السياق اود ان اشدد ان وقف القتال وضمان
حمايه المدنيين هي من ضمن اهم اولوياتنا
في دوله قطر
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني دينيز
شنيهاال ان دوله قطر قدمت مساعدات انسانيه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 100 مليون دولار واضاف
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع رئيس الوزراء
وزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني الذي يزور كييف اضاف ان
المساعدات القطريه ستخصص لاعاده بناء نظام
الرعايه الطبيه والتعليم وازاله الالغاء
لاعاده بناء اوكرانيا واريد ان اشكر السيد
رئيس الوزراء لتخصيص مبلغ 100 مليون دولار
للمساعدات الانسانيه لاوكرانيا سنوجه هذه
الاموال لمجالات الصحه وتطهير الاراضي
المزروعه بالالغام ومجالات اخرى تتعلق
بالاكل